Film Courage: How did you first
hear about virtual production?
Film Director/Producer/Writer/Owner of
Sutliff Studios - Virtual Productions,
Keith Sutliff: Virtual production really
became big and known from the Mandalorian
TV show from Disney. That's kind of like where
I got a taste of it and really heard about it,
2019 around Covid (maybe 2020). That's when I
first really heard about it and really started
extensively researching it and saw the the
power and the capabilities and all the things,
what can be done with that really can benefit
and help people and filmmakers and companies
with film with filming for their whever
they're trying to shoot whatever project.
Film Courage: How many movies or TV shows can
you name right now that you
feel use virtual production?
Keith: There's a lot, The Mandalorian. I
mentioned one, it's a space movie with Tom Cruise,
I don't remember off my head. There's Lion King.
The Lion King used it. There's been a lot of
commercials that have used it for stuff for like
airplane stuff, car process stuff, commercial for
Samsung or whatever like cell phone commercials,
in a car they don't have to actually go drive out
in the street so they use virtual production
and camera view effects which they parallel.
Film Courage: How did you
decide to build your own studio?
Keith: So this whole studio came about couple
years ago, let's see I was location scouting for
a project in Lancaster [California] in the desert.
I was already researching virtual production and
looking into it and saw the benefits of it but
when I was in Lancaster I was driving out there.
I was in my Jeep and I go on this hilltop area and
of course I'm like I'm don't know where my Jeep
gets stuck so we get stuck in the sand the second
time this happened like a year before it happened
but anyways I get stuck in the sand I'm out the
middle of nowhere the transmission blows out like
transmission's done because I'm trying to get out
of there yeah it took me like an hour to get a tow
truck out there and then he barely could get out
there to where I was so that was like for me a
big turning point to where I was like what that is
like a perfect example of what virtual production
can do for people and help people and companies on
achieving a production where they don't have to go
to the deserts and get stuck in the sand or they
can't access the location or just the the harsh
heat the climate so many different things and
then the long drive to get to the deserts like
Lancaster is an hour and a half from here hour
and 40 minutes so that was kind of what really
sparked my my final green light to say I'm going
to go ahead and do this I just saw it firsthand
like that's just is such a benefit to not have to
deal with that and you have bathrooms locally it's
climate controlled in the studio you don't have to
worry about that versus like getting porta-potties
out to where you're filming and craft services
and base camp it's all done in the studio easy
so after after you got your car home yeah you you
started researching alternatives right I mean I
already was looking in the virtual production but
that was kind of like my final my final say so of
like greenlining going ahead and doing this and
starting virtual studio because of that incident
what happened is just like I mentioned some of
the benefits but that's just one of them I mean
that can change if you're getting a cast and crew
of 20 people out to the desert or snow mountains
and people are getting stuck it's just going to
Productions and like cost your team more money
versus you go to a virtual studio everything's
there like I said before like bathrooms your craft
services your base camp where we're getting stuck
everything's easily right there within a few feet
of you versus having to do all the traveling
and gas for people so it's extra expenses but
yeah that's what was my big turning point how how
hot was it when you were there good question that
was I should have touched based on that that was
actually so that was in 2021-2022 I believe or
early 2022 it was right during the middle of a
heat wave or this the beginning of a heat wave
what just started I didn't know when I went out
there that we were in a heat wave because it was
like day one or two of the Heat Wave and I just
thought like I got out there and like wow it's
really hot out here it was like early September
and I was like it is freaking scorching hot out
here like I didn't think I took my shirt off cuz
I was like waiting for the tow truck and it was
like 115 and I had like a bottle of water and like
a snack bar and that was it and yeah was beginning
of a heat wave a heat Dome I guess we had in La
I think it was early 2022 like I said September
around that time and that's another thing so
just the heat yeah it was it was bad so that
was what also influenced me like wow look at that
people don't have to deal with that I mean how you
how you go film out in a desert in 115° like you
can't you have to wait I mean people are going to
pass out that's liability for you you have medical
staff on standby so yeah versus a virtual studio
on the deal with that how does virtual production
factor into your plans to continue film making
yeah I mean I have my own personal projects that
myself as a company's producing as well they put
out and for the public to see and for distribution
later down the road I've been really focusing on
with my team managing the studio for the most
part this past year since it's been open but
as far as film making currently like with stuff I
have we did like two years ago two oneoff like TV
Pilots I guess you could say one was called
Su city which now on Tube TV and like Vimeo
on demand and then we also did a one off of a for
X-Men fans called Cyclops Chronicles the story of
Scott Summers of the Cyclops character from X-Men
for X-Men fans not for distribution just for fun,
for entertainment purposes, for people to
see anyways we're taking both of those one
of pilots now when we're taking that into the
virtual studio here and we're continuing it in
virtual production entirely in virtual production
100% And the purpose of that is to demonstrate
and show people the capabilities and the power of
virtual production what can really be done and how
it how it looks on camera and how it can benefit
people and help people to achieve something in
a short amount of time and just in general what
virtual production what can be done with it would
just a whole series in general of whatever project
they're trying to make so that's what I'm working
on now and we're in post-production on those two
series I me how did you teach yourself virtual
production and how much of a learning curve is
there well it was that was it was a long process
and I started with learning on Unreal Engine
myself which is the the gameware software program
for people who don't know what that is we call
it a 3D asset in virtual production what's put
on the LED wall so we use LED wall be projection
for virtual production here at the studio and yeah
I started with just like going online going
on YouTube and then reading online and then
I started messing with it myself on my computer I
downloaded on Unreal Engine started learning that
and then when I was researching virtual production
in general and reading about it I got kind of
how it worked sort of but I tell filmmakers and
directors and cinematographers will come in here
it's hard to grasp what it is just by watching on
YouTube and like reading about it you you won't
know until you go out and experience it yourself
like anything experience rules everything in life
on whatever you're trying to do that's number way
number one way you will learn so I didn't really
until I opened the studio and really learned I
didn't really learn all the technical aspects
involved in virtual production and how it really
works until I opened the studio and learned by
experience and it was a lot of trial and error a
lot of just Tech shooting tons of months of that
and just really learning before I made it publicly
available for people to come in and rent out so it
was a big learning curve and a lot of work but
yeah there's a whole know a couple different
aspects of virtual production and one is the
camera tracking solution since what we what we use
here to create what we call parallax on the wall
which is the LED wall moving in the background and
Unison with the Unreal Engine gaming software
and did you have to get a new computer or you
already had one that was compatible I did I had
to get a PC with the graphic card with talked
to a couple buddies and people in the business I
knew what recommended I get a certain PC and the
the right graphic card to power Unreal Engine so
there's no problems so yeah I did have to get a
a good PC to have that so in in addition to the
PC the software and then the LED wall any other
things that you need that you can share sure no
absolutely so I'll kind of touch based on virtual
production like the different elements and what
what's needed and how it works so you have your
LED walls your rear projection right then you have
your your computer computer with Unreal Engine
on it what's then everything's connected from
the LED wall you have a a processor controller
what powers LED wall and then like I said the
computer and then if you have if you're using
Unreal Engine you have that what gets displayed on
LED wall and then for Unreal Engine you have your
camera tracking solution what's basically a camera
tracker what gets mounted on top of the camera and
that camera tracker gets paired in unison with a
in-game camera there's an actual camera in Unreal
Engine called ac camera it gets paired with that
through a plugin right so it gets paired and us
in and when it's paired through the the plugin it
creates what we call parallax on the wall which
is the shifting of the LED panels which is really
it's creating this 3d effect that you're actually
there instead of a static wall when the actor is
moving left and right in front of the screen or
forward or backwards or whatever and the cameras
moving with them it's it's the wall is moving
perspective the wall is moving perspective with
the actual actor because of that camera tracker
so that is one of the big elements of virtual
production so you don't have that static wall
so yeah and then you have your lighting elements
you make sure you light it properly frame it shoot
it on the right lens what you want and put it
with the right foreground practicals and that's
how really helps facilitate this vision
that you're somewhere else in the world.